eh bien vous savez quoi il est pas trop
mal ce week au view 3 pro j'aime bien
commencer comme ça c'est un peu par la
fin qu'est ce que vous en pensez marc
coma tous ordres commentaire j'arrête
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout je
voulais présenter lors d'une découverte
prise en main au mwc à barcelone au mois
de février
joe smartphones que j'ai découvert bien
évidemment comme tout le monde a ce
moment la pensée de tester courant mai
et au final voyez on arrive on est au
mois de juin c'est maintenant que je le
teste et là franchement c'est une
proportion qui est intéressante qui va
dans le bon sens wick autant toujours à
progresser au niveau sont toujours à
améliorer ses produits surtout à
s'adapter à la concurrence qui est plus
en plus rude de plus en plus dur et ils
ont raison de le faire parce que c'est
vrai que depuis 2010 8 dans le milieu de
gamme l'entrée de gamme
il y à une guerre acharnée entre tous
les concurrents ça fait un peu plus d'un
an que shiomi est arrivé il ya aussi le
polio fine art noble c'est vraiment une
grosse grosse grosse guerre il ya cinq
mois c'est très compliqué et point
fabricants comme we con et ils nous ont
proposé cette année deux nouveaux
modèles view 3 3 pro ici on parle du
modèle pour le modèle le plus haut de
gamme ou dans l'autre et bien c'est
comme ça que ça se passe du côté de
chirico alors avant de vous parler de ce
produit je voulais faire une petite
pause temps mort un petit break
[Musique]
alors bien évidemment je découvre plein
de produits mais je rencontre si
beaucoup de personnes qu'il ya des
personnes avec qui je m'entends
vachement bien il y en ad'autres a vécu
dans des rapports plus consensuel et
dont les personnes avec qui je m'entends
très bien il ya hervé hervé vaillant qui
bossait chirico est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie beaucoup et lors du lancement
de la sortie officielle n'est quelques
jours à boulogne
hervé étaient présents pour faire c'est
au revoir à toute l'équipe de ricco à
tout le monde s'en va c'est un moment
fait sympa je veux revenir un petit peu
sur ce moment et puis faire une petite
bise et moi pas tardé parce que
franchement je t'adore
il s'en sort comme ça ça c'est pas plus
rococo mais c'est pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hattstatt elle
hattstatt or moi
il y a
à tort
[Musique]
à quoi
m
boyer
de tout
[Musique]
on y parvient on à la soirée we causse
et
lancement officiel des view3d trois
profs de compagnie c'est ça moi j'ai pas
envie de vous parler de ça moi je vous
parlais de mon vieux papes hervé vais
pas tarder que j'aime très fort et qui
malheureusement ne sera plus dans les
prochaines vidéos de ricco qui va
poursuivre une nouvelle aventure et je
vais lui faire un gros bisou de faire un
gros bisou mon pote parce que parce que
pour moi
hervé fait je jouais pas et vous avez
par exemple pour moi hervé saint génies
de la fête sans génie de la
communication c'est un mec humain que
j'adore qui est qui est balèze et sera
un des premiers mac avec qui j'ai bossé
que j'ai pu rencontrer et qui tout de
suite tu te présentes tout le monde
attend la tuque débat telle personne à
temps meetic le liban c'est vrai j'aime
beaucoup hervé je voulais vous le dire
et voilà je serai content
merci rené rast comédien à la scène
toujours un point à un autre
toujours un plaisir de voir toujours
virtuellement et bien la tournure
violente rbds et c'est vraiment un génie
de la fête
[Musique]
bref alors on va parler de 2 ce
smartphone le view 3 pro de we con
qu'est ce qui est intéressant avec le
vieux trois pros le premier truc qui est
intéressant c'est la montée en gamme
mais oublie qu au niveau du design nous
ont mis un dos en verre c'est la
première fois que oui co2 intègre un dos
en verre sont leurs smartphones et c'est
vrai que c'est quand même plutôt sympa
du plus bel effet c'est joli ce la côte
un peu plus classieux alors qui dit dos
en verre des protections sans quoi votre
smartphone vous allez l'abîmé vous avez
une petite coque de protection
intérieure donc ça c'est cool pour venir
un peu le protéger deuxième point qui
est vraiment très intéressant c'est
l'arrivée du triple module photo sur un
smartphone domique oh ça je vous en
parlais dans quelques instants après le
smartphone est somme toute assez
classique
le capteur ici bouton volume bouton pour
l'allumer vous avez aussi à notre foi
qui est intéressant c'est l'arrivée de
la recharge en usb c'est oui qu'on
proposait jusqu'à présent uniquement du
micro usb ils sont mis un petit peu je
dirais à jour par rapport aux différents
concurrents avec de l'usb c'est ça c'est
plutôt pas mal
vous avez de ce côté là votre tiroir de
cartes sim avec soin de cartes sim soit
une carte sim une carte micro sd pour
venir augmenter le stockage dans votre
smartphone jusqu'à 256 giga soldes si
vous avez une prise jack qui est
conservée ça c'est aussi plutôt
intéressant et un micro pour la
réduction de bruit
si vous vous demandez pourquoi est-ce
que mikko nous conserve une prise jack
directement dans ce smartphone
simplement parce qu'on va acheter un
smartphone entre 250 300 euros en règle
générale on va pas investir dans un
casque bluetooth haute qualité qui vous
coûtera forcément plus cher à l'achat
qu'un café avec une prise jack
l'idée est un constructeur comme ricoh
sur l'entrée de gamme c'est
d'effectivement en conservant cette
prise jack de pouvoir push et plein de
personnes qui vont acheter des casques
moins cher avec la prise jack et du coup
c'est un vrai sens par rapport au
portefeuille du consommateur
autre point qui est intéressant ce
smartphone c'est son grand écran d'un
écran de 6,3 pouces un écran lcd vous
vous en douterez avec un ratio 19/9 et
une résolution full hd + 2340 pixels par
1080 à 409 pixels par pouce cet écran
est plutôt de bonne qualité pour venir
regarder du contenu multimédia vidéos
surfer sur internet regarder vos
applications faire ce que vous voulez ça
va pas être l'écran le plus lumineux
qu'on va retrouver c'est pas celui qui
va vous proposer les couleurs les plus
justes les contrastes les plus dingues
les noirs les
l'infini c'est du scd c'est pas un truc
complètement dingue mais je trouve que
il ya un vrai rendu honnête sur ce
smartphone ou ikos moi pas de ses
consommateurs
il propose un écran qui est quand même
relativement honnête avec des couleurs
assez punchy
la source a malgré tout assez bien alors
on n'est pas sur l'écran le plus
immersif
on a quand même sept ans coach et le
groupe docks est plus une en cochant uc
est quand même assez grande
on a quand même un menton qui est aussi
assez proéminent mais c'est vrai que sur
un smartphone qu'on va venir chercher
dans ce budget là c'est pas pour moi il
perd dérangeant l'évolution de huy qu
est ce qu ils cherchent à faire avec ses
smartphones là ça me paraît vraiment
honnête par rapport aux pendables 2010
ayant seront aussi relativement
intéressant c'est malgré tout l'audio
vous avez juste en parleur mono qui
situe là je trouve que vous avec un
motion qui est pas trop mal public à ces
médiums médium grave pas forcément
pressés dans l'aigu milspec petermann
pas trop mal on n'a pas une très très
grosse puissance mais c'est vrai que
pour regarder des séries écouter de la
musique ou des vidéos sur youtube comme
ça c'est pas dire engendré je dirais
même mieux comme vous avez une prise
jack et conservez vous avez aussi un son
pop avec votre casque qui est quand même
malgré tout assez intéressant alors une
fois de plus elle pas énormément de
puissance on va pas à bord la meilleure
qualité audio directement comme ça avec
son casque mais c'est vrai que par
rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver
ailleurs sans le marché ça me paraît pas
déconner vous avez un et llopez 60 qui
est quand même assez fonctionnel année
soit 4 gigas de ram soit 6 giga de ram
je vais me faire éclater à publishers
cette partie là je suis vraiment nul et
voyez je vous dit il n'y a pas
particulièrement de la grèce me suis mis
en qualité graphique moyenne je trouve
que ça fonctionne quand même
relativement bien on n'est pas du tout
sur un smartphone sans concession c'est
pas forcément le socle plus rapide mais
je trouve que pour un usage un peu
standard pour jouer à des jeux même un
peu abusif de dire qualité graphique
moyenne ça fonctionne pour aller sur les
réseaux sociaux pour faire des emails
pour aller faire des photos en termes de
qualité c'est largement suffisant de
libre il ya une certaine limite quand
même qui va se faire notamment au niveau
du mode portrait lorsque vous allez
venir faire des photos je le montre dans
quelques instants mais c'est vrai que
sinon pour un usage courant
une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme après en
terme de stockage y avait deux
possibilités soit 64 de stockage 68 que
pouvait monter tous les deux grâce à une
carte microsd
jusqu'à 256 giga via notre poids sans
qu'elles en oublient qu a vraiment
progressé c'est au niveau de l'autonomie
vous avez une grosse batterie de 4000
milan perd heures que vous allez pouvoir
regarder votre smartphone
entre un jour et demi à deux jours ça
dépend vraiment de votre utilisation
vous avez en plus de la recharge en usb
type c c'est pas la recharge la plus
rapide du monde mais si vous avez un
petit peu de temps devant vous sera
parfaitement d'affaires du pôle vie
l'ouest fondent sur un android 9 paille
c'est quasiment un android stockent se
dit quasiment pas ce que vous avez quand
même oui qu launcher est maintenant le
gros focus qui est fait sur ce
smartphone c'est justement la première
fois que vous avez chirico un triple
module photo vous avez une caméra
principale de 12 mégapixels on
absolument aucune information sur
l'ouverture vous avez une seconde caméra
de 13 mégapixels c'est un ultra
grand-angle de 120 degrés et puis vous
avez à la fin une caméra de 5 mégapixels
qui est là pour le mode portrait pour
les faits évoqués pourrait filmer au
maximum en full hd à 30 images par
secondes vous avez un zoom numérique x 4
et à l'avant cachés ici dans cette
petite encoche devant une caméra de 16
mégapixels et de la même manière c'est
absolument aucune information sur
l'ouverture et bien croyez moi ou pas je
trouve que le boulot est quand même
relativement bien fait de la part de huy
collé dessus bien fait sur la caméra
principale
le reste c'est un peu moins bon je vous
montre les photos que j'ai fait avec mon
vieux trois pros directement sur mon mac
comme ça vous verrez bien c'est vrai
quand on est sur une photo comme ça ces
prises avec le capteur principal c'est
quand même je trouve assez bien pour
trouver à leur bourse survient souvent
plus tôt la perdre en qualité mais on
retrouve quand même vachement de détail
au niveau des fleurs au niveau des
gouttes de pluie je trouve que c'est
vachement bien et assez qualitatif
ensuite dès que vous à regarder son
grand angle tout de suite c'est
vachement bien le grand angle il a du
mal à venir faire un point sur une zone
principale et là on perd quand même en
qualité pareil capteur principal
regarder on voit bien les gouttes on a
bien le détail on voit bien le veinage
au niveau des feuilles pour moi c'est
bien on emploi qui est vraiment fait sur
le devant est la même avec ce grand
angle il ya tout de suite voyez le
centre complètement flou derrière c'est
plus net on a un effet un peu plus
arrondis pour trouver là sur les morts
la même chose avec le castor normal pour
trouver le lien ici sur votre premier
plan tous vos feuilles la lumière et a
cédé à capter les couleurs sont assez
naturel un peu saturé n'est pas trop ça
me paraît quand même assez juste
derrière tout ça un petit peu flou rien
de bien garde là dessus et dès qu'on
passe sur le grand temps je suis désolé
c'est pareil on s'est retrouvé quelque
chose devant qui est flou quelque chose
qui est un peu plus mais derrière on a
vraiment cette déformation ici au niveau
de la photo
pas bien corriger d'un point de vue
logiciel par exemple soit le capteur
principal des gouttes d'eau qui sont
bien rendus du détail ça c'est joli mais
je suis rapprochée pour venir faire une
photo d'un peu plus près c'est un zoom
c'est vraiment me rapprochant que
l'appareil voyez c'est quand même
vachement de détails et c'est juste que
c'est vraiment vraiment juste comme ça
la même manière j'ai pris des feuilles
avec les gouttes des chenilles bon c'est
pas mal hein voyez c'est un peu sur
explosé sur le dessus ça c'est un peu
dommage dit c'est un peu flou dès qu'on
est pas tout de suite dans le champ
diack mais dès qu'on est dedans c'est
pas mal le rendu à ces qualifs c'est
parce qu'elle mieux c'est parce qu'être
plus parfait mais c'est pas mal
et dès qu'on passe tout une voyage paf
sur notre caméra ça devient un peu floue
au centre l'arrière-plan est un peu
mieux et c'est un petit peu plus jeune
que ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver par
rapport à une photo normale présente le
tableau principal côté caméra de celle
où c'est pas mal
rien à dire particulier de ce côté là et
par contre il est très mauvais en soi
une nuit c'est pas du tout son point
fort un la voyez j'ai pris ma figurine
derrière on voit absolument rien on
devine mais c'est vraiment très très
mauvaise qualité là dessus et le mode
portrait pourrait paraître pas mal
lorsqu'on le regarde comme ça mais en
réalité il ya un petit peu des tours et
des fois grands coups de hache
vous voyez là par exemple derrière ces
mets badge qui sont juste là et là il a
eu beaucoup de malades et uri alors ça
ça vient aussi de la faute du soc de
médiathèque et llopez 60
il n'a pas forcément bien faire le
boulot là dessus il a un peu de mal au
niveau des cheveux on a un peu de flou
sur le côté c'est parce qu'ils aident
mieux et au niveau des doigts bon voilà
c'est pas anormal sur un socle de cette
gamme là il a un petit peu de mal mais
là où ça se voit vraiment s'étendre très
flagrant si au niveau des badges
verrouille tout de suite ça se voit et
même comme ça tout de suite c'est pas du
tout cas lit lorsque j'ai pas les badges
derrière ça se voit un petit peu moins
mais pareil je pense que oui au niveau
de détourage il ya beaucoup de mal avec
le vieux troyes provigo continue
d'améliorer sa gamme d'aller plus loin
d'améliorer pas mal de points et de
progresser et se mettre plus à jour face
à la concurrence donc ça c'est pour moi
le gros focus est le gros point positif
sur ce smartphone à côté de ça vous avez
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé du
bluetooth 4.2 est un produit qui me
semble somme toute assez honnête qu'on
peut trouver à deux tarifs différents 4
gigas de ram 64 go de stockage à 249
euros et 6 jets garde ram 128 go de
stockage à 299 euros vue pour seulement
tarifaire je trouve assez intéressant au
niveau de ce qui peut proposer
maintenant j'ai toujours un petit peu
dubitatif par rapport à la concurrence
est-ce qu'il va réussir à coexister par
rapport aux concurrents chinois qui sont
plus en plus pressants qu'ils ont plus
en plus difficile on s'est cru qu est un
petit peu dans le dur
ils ont un peu fêlé créé
âge en france en proposant un plan de
départs volontaires c'est un début
d'année un peu compliqué pour la marque
est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à progresser
à continuer à s'imposer ils sont très
forts dans le segment autour des 100
euros
dès qu'on arrive sur des smartphones aux
alentours des 250 300 euros sont un peu
moins fort c'est un peu plus difficile
pour eux néanmoins il monte un vrai
savoir faire une vraie volonté avec ce
view 3 pro est en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que par rapport aux 8 qu on
pouvait trouver il ya quelques années on
est quand même vraiment passé à une
nouvelle époque à une nouvelle ère de
wilko donc ça je trouve assez
intéressant
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous en
bas en commentaire est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu des smartphones de vico je sais
quand je poste une vidéo sur mikko il ya
souvent au népal à beaucoup de
commentaires assez négatifs qu'ils wilko
sait si c'est ça l'ancien wiko peut-être
les nouveaux produits de ricco s'est
quand même relativement différent je
m'adresse plus tôt personnes qui ont eu
des modèles de l'année dernière view 2
view de pro view de plus qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes satisfait quel est
votre tour est ce que vous avez eu des
déconvenues
et qu'est ce que vous pensez là je parle
à tout le monde à ce vieux ou trois pros
est ce que vous pourriez acheter oui non
quoi comment un état peut dire tout ça
en bas et puis surtout des smartphones
où il y écrit salah designed in france
c'est plutôt rare ça c'est un point
vraiment très très positif vous invite à
lire tout ce que vous en pensez en
bicycle intéresse vous avez aussi un
lien en bas dans la description sur ce
je vous embrasse tous et à demain
ciao
[Musique]